wenn sie erklären müssen was Chat GPT
ist wie würden sie es erklären sie haben
Enkel nehme ich an
ja zwei Enkelkinder aber die sind im
Babyalter mein Schwiegersohn hat mir ein
Geburtstagsbrief über Chat GPT
geschrieben der März ja der war
mittelmäßig und wie fanden sie das also
jetzt nur zwischenmenschlich meine ich
jetzt
nicht
ganz neu gezeigt wie das geht
also
der Begriff Revolution
ist ein großes Wort
kommen wie immer Fluch und Segen
zugleich ich rate alles in allem
zugelassenheit und sie haben verstanden
wie das funktioniert ja mit Sicherheit
naja ich weiß nicht genau was künstliche
Intelligenz ist die beiden Experten
werden das erklären hier ist es ja
glaube ich so dass alle vorhandenen
Wortbestandteile wenn klug
zusammengesetzt und abgehoben
so besonders kreativ muss das noch nicht
sein also ja und wo fängt dann
künstliche Intelligenz an das würde mich
auch selber interessieren bisher
jedenfalls hoffe ich dass der Mensch mit
Kreativität mit Gefühlen mit Stimmungen
dem Computer noch überlegen ist
sie haben haben sie das nicht immer
erzählt ein Konzert gesehen
der deutschen telekom-stiftung wir
kümmern uns um die Bildung junger
Menschen im Bereich Mathematik
Naturwissenschaften Digitalisierung und
IT und sehen gibt es natürlich auch eine
Nähe zur Telekom und die hat finanziert
ein Projekt das auf der Basis von
Notizen Skizzen von Beethoven
die zehnte Sinfonie die die unvollendete
komponiert wird naja sie war noch nicht
so vollendet wie macht das andere aber
es gaben und das mit mit vielen Experten
da können sie Intelligenz ist das
zustande gekommen das auch hier in
Hamburg aufgeführt worden das Ergebnis
war mäßig
okay es war eine tolle Leistung aber das
Genie Beethovens war unerreicht okay
Alena Büchs bevor wir gleich Sascha Lobo
auch fragen was das eigentlich technisch
ist hat eben gerade so sagt ja ob das so
intelligent ist weiß ich gar nicht was
es gibt ein sehr schönen Begriff für
diese large language Models also diese
diese großsprachlichen Modelle das ist
ein stochastischer Papagei was war
passiert ist nämlich dass der mit
Milliarden von Texten befüttert wird und
dann im Prinzip die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ausrechnet mit der das nächste Wort
kommt mit hoher Präzision und weil das
mit so unglaublich viel Daten gefüttert
ist wird das sehr gut aber es bleibt ein
Papagei und deswegen ist das von Genie
immer noch relativ weit entfernt ich
finde das ist ein ganz schönes
um wahrscheinlich
Statistiken
Fähigkeiten sind das die sind
ausgezeichnet und eine ganz fantastische
Simulation also wirklich
das ist erwähnt worden es ist eigentlich
nicht mehr möglich zu erkennen ob da auf
der anderen Seite ein Mensch oder eben
eine Maschine arbeitet und das ist auch
eine der großen Herausforderungen das
ist eins der großen Probleme also
noch sozusagen eher eher entspannt erst
noch den Lehrer kurz fragen ja den
Gymnasiallehrer Blume wie schauen Sie
darauf ist das eine echte Revolution
oder ist das dass man immer sagen würde
na ja müssen uns jetzt keine großen
Sorgen machen weil
begreifen wirkliches verstehen echte
Intelligenz ist was anderes ne ich würde
sagen es kommt drauf an wie man dem
Ganzen begegnet ich fand gerade ein Wort
sehr sehr interessant nämlich das der
fantastischen Simulation
Schule ist ja eigentlich ein Ort wo man
irgendwann begreift dass es um Aneignung
geht ich gehe dahin nicht um eine
fantastische Simulation zu erleben
sondern das haben alle schon eine
Prüfungen versucht fantastischen
Simulation
wahrscheinlich auch noch darüber
sprechen müssten aber was ich damit
meine ist diese fantastische
fantastische Simulation die ja auch
anders erzeugt werden kann zum Beispiel
wenn ich ein Papa eine Mama habe die mir
bei meinen Hausaufgaben hilft ja GFS in
Baden-Württemberg das ist die
gleichwertige Feststellung von
Schülerleistung also Ausarbeitung und
Referat hieß immer schon ganze Familie
schafft das verändert sich jetzt das
schafft nicht mehr die ganze Familie
sondern da kann die KI mithelfen aber
ich glaube genau deshalb muss es eben in
die Schule rein damit es nicht darum
geht wer täuscht jetzt hier eigentlich
wen sondern alle wissen wir können das
produktiv benutzen und deshalb müssen
wir es auch direkt einsetzen okay und
noch ganz kurze Nachfrage wenn Schüler
Schülerin kommt zu Ihnen und und hat ihn
sehr schön mit den Faust interpretiert
oder erklärt was auch immer merken Sie
ob das der Bot die Maschine geschrieben
hat oder der der denkt der zuständig
meine Schülerinnen und Schüler sind
natürlich fantastisch das heißt im
simulieren
eine Interpretation ich ich meine das
durchaus ernst denn es ist so 12 Klasse
Interpretation von voicek in dem Fall
nicht Faust da haben die Schülerinnen
und Schüler das zusammen mit mir
ausprobiert und sie waren besser warum
weil Chat GPT
momentan ja noch nicht alles auf alles
zugreifen kann das heißt da wo es
konkret wird da wo die belegen kommen
und auch da wo man problematisiert da
ist momentan noch Schluss das können
meine Schülerinnen und Schüler besser
okay das ist erstmal die gute Nachricht
so und jetzt geht der Blick zu Sascha
Lobo von dem ich das Gefühl habe
versucht die ganze Zeit und das war ja
auch der Tenor eines Textes den sie vor
einiger Zeit habe ich für die Kollegen
vom vom Spiegel veröffentlicht haben wo
bleibt sozusagen die große Aufruhr wo
bleibt die große Diskussion um das Thema
sie sagen das ist eine echte Revolution
warum ist der Revolution ist darüber
reden wir gleich können Sie einmal
erklären was das technisch ist was
passiert da
man muss die Technologie die dahinter
steht GPT deswegen steht für
generative pre-traint Transformer und
dieses pre-train ist sehr entscheidend
weil es bedeutet dass die geübt hat und
das muss man trainiert genau diese
künstlichen Intelligenz wird trainiert
mit Daten man muss das aber diese
Technologie GPT begreifen als Maschinen
sprechen jetzt auch unsere Sprache und
wir können Ihnen sagen was wir von ihnen
wollen und sie können die Sprache selbst
als Instrumenten nutzen das ist die
eigentliche Revolution die dahinter
steht deswegen ist zum Beispiel ein Teil
auch Bilder schöpferisch selbst
herzustellen und die sind wirklich nach
meinem Dafürhalten neu denn da würde ich
ganz entschieden wieder sprechen was da
passiert ist kreativ was da passiert
durch die Maschinen ist schöpferisch und
alles andere als ein Papagei und wenn
man das so drastisch formulieren würde
dann müsste man sagen ja gut also das
was wir Menschen machen das auch 99,9
Prozent beeinflusst von irgendwelchen
manchmal unbewussten Einflüssen manchmal
manche Kollegen ein bisschen bewussterer
Einflüsse aber von Einflüssen aller Art
die kreative Leistung die kann man den
Maschinen beim besten Willen nicht mehr
absprechen fürchte ich aber an Papa
Papagei muss nicht unkreativ sein aber
ehrlich
was technisch dahinter genau
dieses Wort trainiert genau ganz konkret
wer trainiert diese Maschine ich habe
noch nicht mit einem mit meinem Sohn der
Bereich Informatik auch unterwegs ist
gesprochen der sagt Papa das bessere
Wort wäre eben nicht künstliche
Intelligenz sondern Maschinen learning
also maschinell ist lernen das ist
tatsächlich wahr wenn man künstlichen
Intelligenz als Begriff übersetzen
wollen würde dann könnte man so im
Alltags gebrauchen lernen musste
Erkennung auf Speed sagt und das Lernen
ist deswegen so wichtig weil es bedeutet
dass Sie immer besser wird das heißt die
künstliche Intelligenz wird immer besser
mit jedem Ergebnis was man überprüfen
kann wird eine künstliche Intelligenz
besser darin aber
muss der Erkennung heißt ja ich erkenne
bestehende Muster die kann ich werde
variieren der Witz von Kreativität
Innovation ist aber gerade neue Muster
zu schaffen auszubrechen aus bestehende
Denkstrukturen
aber auf die kommt es an es tut mir leid
es zeigt sich tatsächlich dass die
Mustererkennung auch als Prinzip der
Muster Durchbrechung funktioniert wir
haben ja heute schon eine KI die Musik
schreiben kann die kann man wirklich
nicht mehr beethoven-bereich würde ich
sagen kann ich nicht einschätzen aber
einen anderen Bereichen sowas Chat
einfach so Charts Musik angeht kann man
das nicht mehr unterschreiben will noch
einmal ganz kurz weil wir jetzt schon
sehr technisch sozusagen unterwegs sind
einmal ganz kurz die Anwendungsbereiche
dann versteht man vielleicht besser
warum es geht also
ganz simpel ich setze mich an den
Computer ich sage der Maschine erklär
mir einmal wer Sascha Lobo ist und dann
kommt ein ähnlicher Text wie den ich
gerade vorgetragen habe ich könnte aber
auch sagen
ich bräuchte jetzt irgendwie eine
Zusammenfassung über das Wirken von
Sascha Lobo im rap-stil da würde das
auch kommen oder in der Sprache von
Heinz Erhardt absolut oder ich könnte
dir sagen Spiel mir weil sie nicht eine
Musik von Dieter Bohlen vor der eine
Dieter Bohlen geschrieben haben könnte
genau das würde die Maschine dann
sozusagen einfach ausspucken aber es
wäre nicht immer hart you're Soul und es
wäre auch nicht Brother Louis sondern es
wäre was was Neues etwas Neues
zusammengesetzt natürlich aus kleinsten
Baustein sozusagen Atomen der
Kreativität ja schon gab das neue
zusammengesetzt und dass die
schöpferische Leistung und vor allem
sinnvoll kombiniert miteinander Schule
dann würde das was bedeuten Herr Blume
was können Schüler Anwendungsbereich
jetzt bevor wir technisch werden also
was können die machen also grundsätzlich
können Sie sich natürlich in jedem Fach
und auf jeder Sprache jede mögliche
offene Frage so beantworten lassen dass
sie formal korrekt scheint um nämlich zu
beurteilen um ob etwas formal korrekt
ist was rausgekommen ist muss man ja
zunächst auch mal in der Lage sein das
zu beurteilen
der erste Stufe prinzipiell Aufsatz über
genau und nicht nur das also ich denke
das was ich so faszinierend finde und
was Schülerinnen und Schüler auch so
faszinierend finde ist dass man ja sagen
kann schreibe mir bitte eine Einleitung
werden es gerade von Goethes Faust und
dann sagt man die ist mir noch zu kurz
bitte verlängere sie oder ähm für noch
weitere 7 Wörter ein oder da kommen wir
dann in den Bereich der sogenannten
Proms also oder beziehungsweise mega
Proms ich kann Chat GPT sagen pass mal
auf du bist ein Experte für Literatur
Wissenschaft und du hast seit Jahren zum
Themengebiet und dann wird Goethe
geforscht und dann verändert sich
plötzlich auch die Antwort und wir
tatsächlich konzise und und länger und
wie man es eben möchte und man kann
danach fragen ich muss nur einen Satz zu
Sascha Lobo eben sagen das ist sehr
wichtig dass man nicht sagt dass das
nicht schöpferisch ist oder unkreativ
das will ich nicht gesagt haben ich
glaube es ist sehr wichtig sich klar zu
machen dass das eine gewisse
Qualitätsstufe erreichen kann auch was
schöpferische Gehalte anbelangt aber
wenn es in die Tiefe geht wenn es und da
kann man darüber streiten was ist echte
Kreativität ne was ist echte
Schaffenskraft wenn es darum geht das
wirklich etwas dabei rauskommt was
genuin
durchbrechend neu ist dann scheitert das
noch wir haben das im wir haben das im
Hochschulbereich ausprobiert also wir
haben diese Maschine
haben sie eingegeben ich habe dieses ich
habe Chat GP verschiedene paper
schreiben lassen also wissenschaftliche
Arbeiten weil wir natürlich alle am
Anfang sofort Angst hatten um Himmels
willen das schreibt jetzt unsere
Publikation Aufgabe konkret die Aufgabe
war schreibt mir einen Artikel über
assistierten so sieht in Deutschland und
was die Herausforderungen in der
gegenwärtigen aktuellen ethischen und
regulatorischen Debatte darstellt
natürlich und dann kam ein Artikel raus
der
eine mittelmäßige Zusammenfassung
dargestellt hat der ganz viele echte
Fehler enthielt und vor allem
Halluzination also Belege beispielsweise
von Artikeln die nur Expertinnen und
Experten noch erkennen als falsch die
sind nämlich nicht gibt die sich jetpity
ausdenkt das ist ein bekanntes Problem
bei Chelsea kreativ ehrlich ehrlich
ich habe nur gesagt das ist insofern ein
Papagei als es verstoffwechselt was es
gibt und das dann in neuer Form
zusammenbauen wie viele Seiten waren das
wie lang war das und die die 15 Seiten
ja natürlich man kann sich damit Bücher
schreiben
und wenn man aber dann in die Tiefe
schaut und das ist aber das muss ich
dazu sagen natürlich Experten Level dann
fehlt
der originelle neue Gedanke das ist
flach das verstehe ich aber ich hätte
das auch machen können nein und jetzt
kommt was wichtiges einfach
reingeschrieben und dann werden diese 15
Seiten gekommen oder nicht na klar meine
also das
beeindruckt gewesen sie jetzt nicht aber
nein ich bin total beeindruckend
ich bin total ich bin total beeindruckt
von den Fähigkeiten denn so etwas hat
ein Level von jemandem der in der
Wissenschaft schon ein Weilchen
ausgebildet ist also das ist weiß Gott
nicht eine triviale Fähigkeit aber doch
auf Cocktailparty schon mal sehr
Eindruck machen weil wir über
Kreativität gesprochen haben weil wir
über Genie gesprochen haben weil wir
über das reden was das spezifisch
menschliches ist von dem ich tatsächlich
Glaube und vielleicht ist das ein
Streitpunkt was jedenfalls noch und auch
eine Weile absehbar Chat und solche
Systeme noch nicht können da ist noch
eine Wegstrecke zu gehen
ganz kurz noch sie haben es mal mit
Clausewitz gemacht ja da war die Frage
was spricht für den Satz der Krieg ist
die Fortsetzung der Politik mit einer
Mittel das haben sie eingegeben kam drei
schöne Seiten raus an Mitarbeiter der
Stiftung hat das eingegeben und dann hat
er gefragt was spricht gegen diesen Satz
und dann kam ebenso kluger Aufsatz raus
wie viele Seiten wieder drei drei vier
der nette Mann also in der 12 Klasse 11
Klasse bei Ihnen sicher gut abgeben
können aber das ist sehr gutes
repetieren von
vorhandenen gutes zusammensetzen also
wie alle haben ja auch gesagt Schule
bricht zusammen mit Wikipedia Wikipedia
ist nun statisch wenn man so will und
das ist jetzt dynamisch genau und das
ist ja erst der Anfang sind ja andere
Firmen die auch sowas machen
nur irgendwie jetzt in angststörer zu
verfallen dafür haben wir nur mal
erklären worum es geht und das was da
sie sind sehr kluger Mensch das was
daraus kam hat sie überzeugt ja das war
jetzt eine einseitige Darstellung was
für diesen Satz spricht und
dagegen genau ich bin kein Lehrer aber
im
Politikunterricht hätte ich dafür
wahrscheinlich eine gute Note gegeben
nachdem was ich gelesen habe das Sammeln
der Informationen Ende 2001
also alles was danach ist kennt er nicht
und das ist natürlich wenn man so will
eine große Schwäche also da muss man
jetzt verschiedene Sachen entgegnen das
erste ist natürlich jetzt im
geniebereich gut mir kommt jetzt nicht
so vor als sei im deutschen Büroalltag
Kreativität auf Genie Level besonders
häufig gefragt
der zweite Punkt das stimmt wirklich
dass ähm jetzt speziell Chat GPT noch
relativ viele Sachen und falsch macht
das liegt nicht nur an dem
Informationslevel sondern eine ganze
Reihe von Trainingseinheiten das Chat
GPT funktioniert mit
175 Milliarden sogenannten Parametern es
kann ein bisschen übersetzen wie Worte
und Wortteile
175 Milliarden was ist das machen sie es
mal gucken oder Wort Teile und der die
die Modell unterwegs sind
kann das Wikipedia sein das kann ein
Forum Eintrag von sein
ein Programm sein
das kann alles sein absolut die
Ankündigung von einer glanzssendung kann
das sein also generell Texte im Netz hat
dieses Programm untersucht und dann hat
es untersucht in welcher Beziehung
stehen diese Worte und Wortteile und das
bei 175 Milliarden von diesen Worten
oder Wortteilen und das ist aber Moment
das ist der Stand
2023 und zwar im Frühjahr wir reden aber
davon und das muss man begreifen dass
wir noch ganz am Anfang sind ist
wirklich auch mit den Fehlern die
passieren nicht nur das schöne Programm
nicht auf das Internet jetzt zugreift
also gar nicht weiß was er nicht
Zwischenzeit passiert ist sondern vor
der Tür steht GPT vor 4 4 das ist Level
3 sozusagen
und irgendwann im Verlauf des Jahres
vermutlich vielleicht wird es ein
bisschen verschoben kommt GPT vor und
das wird an sage und schreibe zehn bis
20 billion brunnenparametern trainiert
das heißt 100 mal mehr Daten werden
dadurch geprügelt was dieses Lernmodell
angeht und das wiederum bedeutet wenn
wir jetzt schon nicht ganz Genie Level
sind dann kann man sich ungefähr
ausmalen was gptv mit sich bringt wenn
es ja Wahnsinn 175 Milliarden versus was
das Zehnfache nee
10 Billionen 10 bis 20 Billionen und die
Zahl dieser Lernvorgänge kann man so
verkürzt sagen die geht in Bereiche rein
dass wir schon von einer Art Intelligenz
sprechen müssen und das ist dann halt
auch nicht mehr der falsche Begriff
Intelligenz sondern das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Begriff zumindest wenn man
Intelligenz betrachtet als
Problemlösungsfähigkeit
und was mich technisch noch mal
interessiert mich irgendwo von Ihnen
gelesen fand ich total interessant der
Trick zum Beispiel von Google ist das
die quasi zu Hause oder deren eigenen
Servern der wo immer dann zu Hause ist
das Netz das Internet nachbauen um dann
extrem schnell auf all diese
Informationen sozusagen das gesammelte
Wissen der Menschheit zugreifen zu
können ein bisschen vereinfacht aber
google speichert auf den eigenen Servern
quasi das ganze Internet das
durchsuchbare Internet um das schneller
und nach eigenen Kriterien durchsuchen
zu können was eigentlich los ist so und
das funktioniert ähnlich oder wie läuft
das da gibt's unterschiedliche
Herangehensweisen das sind eigentlich
auch drei stufige lernen Modelle und nur
in einem von denen sind halt diese
vielen Parameter diese vielen Worte und
Vorteile die untersucht werden in
anderen Teilen
überprüft man ob die bisherigen Lösungen
auch nur ansatzweise richtig sind und
das tun zum einen selbst Maschinen ne
also das ist tatsächlich so dass
überleben gibt es überhaupt sind und zum
anderen diese sogar Menschen das heißt
da sind dann Menschen die versuchen
rauszufinden ist eine bestimmte Antwort
auf eine bestimmte Frage sinnvoll oder
nicht und so kann man die künstliche
Intelligenz immer wieder füttern und
klüger werden lassen die lernt die wird
von alleine besser und jetzt stellt sich
eine ganz essenzielle Frage aber wir
haben jetzt nur darüber geredet wie gut
ist das und was kann das schon und wie
nah ist das ein echter
Intelligenz die Frage die sich dann
anschließt ist
sollten wir das eigentlich wollen ja das
kann beantworten
die Frage ist sollten wir wollen dass
wir so gar nicht mehr selbst sozusagen
in den letzten Enden menschlicher
Kreativität und das genießt
unterscheiden können
das ist eine Technologie ist von einer
menschlichen Leistung denn dass das hat
ganz viele Implikationen für
Urheberschaft
verurteilskraft und für ganz wichtige
Fragen die uns bewegen dass wir die
Qualitäten dieser Technologien super
nutzen werden können und dass uns die
uns ganz viel Potenzial bringt also das
würde ich auch auf jeden Fall
unterschreiben aber wenn die wirklich so
gut wird dann stellt sich die Frage
müssen wir das eigentlich irgendwie
kennzeichnen
da kommt der Gymnasiallehrer ins Spiel
also sie kriegen jetzt nach Hause
Aufgabe ja also ganz grundsätzlich ja
aber übrigens auch schon in der
Realschule und in einer bergrealschule
gearbeitet ich finde die die Frage
sollten wir das wollen oder nicht wollen
immer deshalb schwierig weil wir es mit
Entwicklung zu tun haben die stattfinden
die sowieso passieren werden
oder Fluch muss ich an dein altes Buch
denken zumindest mit Fragezeichen nicht
wichtige Frage für mich wäre die
richtige Frage wie wollen wir lernen im
21 Jahrhundert gestalten und ganz viele
Dinge die einfach gerade so ein bisschen
durch die Luft geschmiert sind waren
ganz zentral erstens lernen ist ein
sozialer Prozess in Schulen wird
soziales Miteinander oftmals
sanktioniert und zum Beispiel jede
Prüfung funktioniert ja noch so als wenn
es weder die künstliche Intelligenz
Wikipedia oder Lektüre Hilfen geben
würde also darüber müssen wir nachdenken
darüber wird auch nach und nach das
andere Kreativität wurde gerade genannt
was ist Kreativität ist eine sehr
abstrakte Diskussion aber es ist Schulen
zumindest in der Form wie wir sie gerade
haben sind ja nicht gerade bekannt dafür
die Kreativität und die Talente der
unterschiedlichen Individuum besonders
zu fördern also für mich ist die Frage
wie wollen wir lernen im 21 Jahrhundert
gestalten und eine Antwort wäre
zumindest zu sagen dass wir Schülerinnen
und Schülern die Möglichkeit geben
ihre
kulturzugangsgeräte wie man ja
Smartphones auch nennen kann so
einzusetzen dass wir eben all das was
gerade passiert nicht ausschließen
sondern produktiv nutzen weil wenn wir
das nicht tun wenn wir das nicht tun
dann machen es die Schüler ohne uns sie
haben das so schön gesagt sie haben mich
zitiert hausaufgaben sind tot Komma wenn
wir das versuchen Weg zu ignorieren wenn
wir sagen na ja das gibt's jetzt aber so
richtig interessiert mich das nicht dann
sind Hausaufgaben tot dann wird es zu
einem imitations- und täuschungsspiel
ich mache eine Klassenarbeit mit Shetty
BT ja das kann man übrigens auch super
machen ich kann meinen Unterricht auch
planen lassen ihre Redaktion kann
übrigens die Sendung auch durchplanen
lassen könnte sich wobei anders der
Verlag der Spiegel könnte sich Sascha
Lobo Kolumnen schreiben lassen habe ich
schon getan von der Maschine getan
ja also man muss sich die Frage sie sind
noch am Anfang haben sie es gemerkt ja
ich habe es drüber geschrieben dass ich
war so sehr war ich dann hätte es jemand
gemerkt ja aber hauptsächlich nur weil
ich mir ständig neue Worte ausdenke und
das hat sich die Maschine noch nicht
getraut bzw muss man halt wirklich auch
noch nicht ne wir sind das immer sich
vergegenwärtigen wir sind ja noch am
Anfang ja Chat GPT die Version GPT 3 die
Technologie dahinter steht die hat ja
z.B die Aufnahmeprüfung der Harvard love
School geschafft das bayerische Abitur
hat sie noch nicht geschafft
okay
Luft nach oben aber und das ist das
lernende bei machine learning bei
künstliche Intelligenz die verbessert
sich und irgendwann wird sie wohl auch
das bayerische Abitur
schaffenberg irgendwie ja
Baden-Württemberg ich weiß es nicht ich
weiß es nicht und ähm ehrlich gesagt so
so einfach ist das tatsächlich auch
nicht aber ich fand es gerade spannend
dass das auch ich wollte noch gar nicht
pessimistisch sein ehrlich gesagt weil
sie gesagt haben jetzt kommt mal was
optimistisch ich bin auch optimistisch
solange wir das nicht wieder weg
ignorieren denn Schulen sind ja einfach
starre Systeme sie haben gerade selber
gesagt Chat GPT und alles was nachkommt
ist sehr dynamisch also es wäre schön
wenn wir das so ein bisschen
parallelisieren
was mich zuversichtlich stimmt ganz
früher war es so es gab ein kleines
Menschheitswissen und Schule und
Menschheit war darauf bezogen dass das
vielleicht möglichst viele können
sollten nachdem die Experten das Zugeben
mussten das andere auch lernen dürfen
sondern ist das Wissen größer geworden
dann hat man gesagt so jetzt müssen wir
ein gewaltbild Allgemeinbildung haben
und exemplarisch lernen man kann nicht
alles lernen jetzt haben wir seit
einigen Jahren hören wir das Wissen
explodiert alle Jahre verdoppelt sich
das aus
so eine ganz schreckliche Nachricht wie
soll die Menschheit damit umgehen und
die gute Nachricht ist jetzt das mit
Hilfe von diesen Instrumenten wer
imstande sind dieses angehäufte wissen
können wir auch von dem ziemlich viel
wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich sinnlos und
wertlos ist Klammer zu das kann man
ordnen das kann man ergänzen das kann
man das kann man dem kann man sich auch
als kleiner Schüler als kleiner Lehrer
als kleiner Politiker als kleiner
Professor dem kann man sich geordnet
zuwenden ohne dass man in der Fülle
erstickt und das finde ich schon mal
eine gute Nacht aber auch noch eine
optimistische Sache sagen und die
schließt anders an was Probleme gesagt
hat
wir müssen das jetzt gestalten das ist
ein wunderbarer Begriff darf ich bevor
wir auf die Schulen kommen noch einmal
ganz schnell auf die Medizin gehen weil
die Medizin ganz spannender Bereich ist
da geht es wirklich um die Wurst also da
sind auch diese Fehler natürlich total
relevant das kann zwischen Leben und Tod
einer wenn dann den Dosierung nicht
stimmt die in so ein ähm
Checker mir gibt oder irgendeinen
entscheidungsassistenzsystem dass ich in
der Medizin habe dann ist das ein echtes
Problem und ich habe auch dieses Problem
dass die Leute diese Vermenschlichung da
betreiben und glauben dass irgendwie auf
der anderen Seite eigentlich ein Arzt
oder eine Ärztin und das ist eigentlich
eine Maschine also bei uns ist das schon
ziemlich intensiv auch teilweise in die
Praxis eingegangen und was man da sieht
ist das hat ein enormes Potenzial und
wenn es noch besser wird umso besser ja
das sind die Dinge die müssen wir dann
da können wir nämlich Fehler die
Menschen ansonsten machen natürlich
vermeiden da können wir Qualität
schaffen die wir mit unseren Gehirn ganz
richtig wie sie sagen dass das
medizinische Wissen das studiert uns ja
auch das können wir gar nicht mehr so
schnell fassen das kann die Maschine
aber
gleichzeitig ist das auch ein Bereich
bei dem wir echt gucken müssen wo könnte
das gefährlich sein was sind da die
Herausforderungen und dann muss man es
klug gestalten und was ich nur nicht
möchte ist dass wir so eine Diskussion
führen so das ist jetzt da das kracht
uns jetzt in die Welt und wir lassen es
irgendwie laufen sondern wir müssen da
natürlich gucken was wollen wir davon
und was nicht konkrete Nachfrage dazu
also in der Medizin haben sie es doch
heute schon ständig mit Menschen zu tun
die zum Arzt kommen und
lose bereits haben und sie eigentlich
nur noch vom Arzt nochmal bestätigt
haben möchten ja das nervt Ärzte auch
unfassbar jetzt kann ich das mit der
Maschine natürlich auch machen und die
sagt man dann pass auf bei folgenden
Symptomen ist sehr davon auszugehen
folgendes und das wäre sozusagen die
richtige Therapie jetzt für dich
wenn man das einsetzt in der Medizin
stellt sich hier für mich dann
irgendwann auch die Frage weil sie
gerade sagten kleiner Fehler kann zu
großen Konsequenzen führen die Frage der
Verantwortung absolut also wer ist denn
dann verantwortlich ganz relevante Frage
bitte bin ich dabei umkomme weil sich
der Arzt es gibt auf die Maschine
verlassen hat wer ist dann
verantwortlich also zwei Dinge die einen
sagen die endverantwortung liegt immer
beim Arzt weil wir jetzt ja schon alle
möglichen Unterstützungssysteme haben
und Arzt oder Ärztin muss das alles
zusammenführen diese ganzen Systeme auch
das was sozusagen die künstliche
Intelligenz jetzt schon kann die können
einzelne Aufgaben die können was sie
sich die Röntgenbilder perfekt Befunden
aber all das andere was dazu gehört dass
ich ein Patienten mit seiner ganz
Patientengeschichte angucke das können
nur Ärztin und Ärzte also ein
Verantwortung die beim Arzt die anderen
sagen moment mal diese Systeme sind
sogenannte black boxes also das sind
sozusagen nicht mehr verstehbare
Algorithmen
das kann der Arzt das kann die Ärzte
überhaupt nicht verstehen also der muss
sich ja auch irgendwie darauf verlassen
und die sagen dann es sind am Ende des
Tages die Programmierer die Hersteller
die die Verantwortung nimmt das ist
ungeklärt bisher auch von den ja das ist
ist es die Firma ist es der der
Algorithmus ja es ist unter Juristin und
Jurist ich habe es gestern noch habe
mich noch mal vor der Sendung habe ich
gesagt ich spreche noch mal kurz mit den
absoluten Experten in diesem Bereich und
der mir ganz klar gesagt das ist ein
nach wie vor ungeklärt und es gibt noch
eine weitere Problematik was ist denn
wenn der Arzt oder die Ärztin irgendwann
sagt ich folge der Empfehlung nicht und
dann geht was so das wird das größte
Problem Ärztin und Ärzte werden sich
verantworten müssen wenn sie der
Empfehlung nicht folgen das ist eine
ganz relevante Diskussion und
wahrscheinlich wird es irgendwie in so
einer mischverantwortung hinausgehen
dass man also heraus arbeitet welcher
Verantwortungsbereich liegt bei den
Ärztinnen und Ärzten und wo sind dann
tatsächlich diejenigen die das technisch
auch aufsetzen
gegebenenfalls auch in der
Mitverantwortung die Frage die sich auch
dann stellt ist wer sollte denn dann
noch Mediziner werden wollen wenn du
dich in weiteren weiten Teil auf
Maschinen Algorithmen blackboxes wie sie
sagen verlässt verlassen musst weil das
ganze Thema wahnsinnig komplex ist aber
am Ende bist du der arme tropft der zu
Verantwortung gezogen wird das kannst
doch nicht sein deswegen wird das wenn
überhaupt eine mischverantwortung sein
das wäre ungerecht in ÄrztInnen und
Essen gegenüber ich möchte noch einen
Satz sagen die große Chance die man in
der Medizin hat und da bin ich wirklich
gespannt ob man das für die Schulen auch
so sehen kann
aber in der Medizin ist das tatsächlich
so die die Hoffnung ist das ist die
positive Vision die Hoffnung ist dass
Ärztin und Ärzte frei gespielt werden
von diesen ganzen Routine Tätigkeiten
die sie machen und wieder viel mehr Zeit
haben Patienten Zuwendung sprechen
wird immer in ärztlicher Verantwortung
bleiben der teil und das sollte es auch
also da ist auch eine Gestaltungsaufgabe
dass wir sagen das muss auch unter
ärztlicher Kontrolle bleiben das ist
leider in Teilen eine komplett virtuelle
Diskussion ja wir haben heute schon eine
Vielzahl von Technologien von den
Menschenleben abhängen und führen auch
nicht die gigantische große Diskussion
hier bei dem Auto x da hat die Bremse
versagt deswegen ist er irgendwo ein
Baum gefahren ob jetzt wer genau dafür
verantwortlich war dass die Bremse
versagt werden
die Macht der Technologie es gibt einen
Bereich der künstlichen Intelligenz der
nennt sich explainable ai also erklärt
künstliche Intelligenz und da sagt die
künstliche Intelligenz ganz genau warum
sie welchen Schritt zu welchem Zeitpunkt
auf welche Weise gemacht hat und erklärt
das für Fachleute und zum Teilen
komplett verständlich
und macht so die Blackbox eben sehr
nachvollziehbar das ist dann keine
Blackbox mehr und wir rechnen nicht
damit wie groß die Macht von genau
solchen Technologien ist wenn sie erst
einmal die Sprache auf einer Ebene
versteht wie sie es heute in Ansätzen
schon tut es gibt eine ganze Reihe von
Leuten die im Netz versuchen die
künstliche Intelligenz
missbrauchbar zu machen also für
irgendwelche lustigen oder gar nicht so
lustigen Scherze und hier sind wir
inzwischen tatsächlich mit der KI so
weit dass wir stimmen von Prominenten
von Politiker in den von allen möglichen
Menschen imitieren können das heißt man
lädt ein großen
Stimmen Archiv hoch das kann Podcast
sein das ist eine Person gesprochen hat
oder eine Rede diese gehalten hat und
dann kann die KI genau in dem Duktus
dieser prominenten Person eine Stimme
erzeugen mit Sachen die man selbst
eingeht die die nie gesagt hat und ganz
ähnlich funktioniert das im Zweifel auch
mit Filmen es ist noch qualitativ noch
nicht da wo man sagen würde um Gottes
Willen aber es ist ehrlich natürlich ist
es schon sehr leicht ist es da es ist
definitiv erahnbar und wir reden ja von
der ständig verbesserten Version davon
das ist ein ahnbar dass wir in den
nächsten Wahlkämpfen in den Vereinigten
Staaten ganz besonders aber auch in der
Weltpolitik eine Form von
Propaganda und Fake News bekommen die
wirklich besorgniserregend ist weil wir
uns als Öffentlichkeit bisher damit
nicht auskennen und dann kommt das Video
Olaf Scholz mit Putin spricht über
irgendwas was ich jemand ausgedacht hat
was man sagt es ist hat wurde gelegt
heimlich aufgenommen es gab es nie aber
es sieht ganz echt aus und plötzlich
haben wir eine völlig neue Front das
Fake News an
das ist Freitag vor dem Bundestagswahl
so etwas da hat man Mühe dass du
dementieren es war einfach Tagen hat
eine massive politische